we're 30 days away from from the world
premiere of goodbye promise and we know
this is something you deal with quite a
bit in your field and so we're just
wondering you typically deal with bigger
cause what we're wondering some some
early advice you can give to us you know
the things that we should be doing right
now for goodbye promise that that we
should do and we're open that in turn
that this could be helpful to other
independent filmmakers that are going to
watch this absolutely absolutely yeah I
mean the first thing I like to do is
kind of work backwards right you know I
i use the cubby system with a lot of the
clients it's like begin with the end in
mind right so if you're an independent
film you don't have a big budget for for
a massive publicity campaign and you're
up against the you know the grain where
your film is a few weeks out for from a
theatrical premiere like you guys I go
backwards and think what do I want to do
I want to pack the house I want to have
positive stories come out about you know
our project to take it to the next level
where other you know it gets picked up
by a network or if it gets sold on VOD
you know we want positive things to come
after it and then you just start working
your way backwards so how do we get the
public there do we have a budget for
advertising if not can we do some kind
of barter deal with a magazine you can
we do a partnership with a online
publication or something any filmmaker
can do that you guys have already won
half the battle because you know by
getting a theatrical screening that's a
very big accomplishment you know a lot
of filmmakers struggle for years get it
you know submit to hundreds and hundreds
of festivals and never the film never
sees a lot of day never gets into a
theater so that's a very big
accomplishment so I think you can you
know possibly partner with a publication
and then I would start thinking about
influencers in the space not only media
and press but people who can create a
social chatter to create a word of mouth
because you're an independent film you
don't have a massive budget to the
studios or even
mini majors so you got to be kind of
creative with it so you know think about
the themes from your film and think
about people in the online space that
can make that can say a few things I can
I can that can start a conversation that
could I pop the screening and bring them
out you can work with those kind of
partners on two levels hey you to talk
about the film to drive the audience
there and be to go on the record and use
their their words as testimonials on
your packaging on your website on
multiple platforms so right now it's
like this is guerilla filmmaking 101 you
know if this is um you know with all the
platforms all the social media with the
Pinterest and the Twitter and Tumblr and
all these platforms that exist right now
you can capitalize on it so going back
to going backwards identify these
influencers you know maybe these 10 to
15 people that can create the online
chatter um so I would use them and I
would also use some good media we create
a hit list of press that you can a
possibly send out screeners to so they
can do some positive reviews you know
your four weeks out it's got to move
quick and then be possibly create some
kind of event a pre-event whether it be
like a small cocktail you know you don't
have a budget to get a massive screening
round table area so you know talk to
your family your friends about hosting
some kind of event where you can invite
maybe some media um to speak with your
cast and speak with yourselves as the
filmmakers you can drive those stories
out what you gotta do though is what I
like to do is I like the time things to
a date for things to hit so all your
campaign where there would be social or
traditional publicity which is we're
talking about press on any bits of news
whether it be my talent talking about
the film to a particular outlet or I get
I don't know a friend of mine that works
in barnes & noble
and he is a big Twitter following and he
can talk about tuning into the screen I
would time everything to put a specific
date for everything to hit that date to
drive traffic to your ticket sales what
I mean by that is if we schedule these
things and we schedule a little event we
do a round table and everyone's talking
we gather everything we tell everyone to
don't post your story until two weeks
from now that Monday and that day is
just you're all out press day they're
sending stuff out and everyone's you're
just getting multiple platform hits
everywhere so people can't be anywhere
without hearing about your film and a
lot of the campaign's work this way um
you know in our case it I mean it's June
first and you know we've been you know
wordpress ourselves and we deal with the
media and we have those same sort of
things were like they tell us and in a
lot of cases they're saying like don't
release any information until that bar
down the other embargoing until that day
so is that the best way to do it where
we can say like literally we don't want
you to release any information until
June first yeah or by that point first
you I film is it too late too late you
want to give them like a couple of weeks
to be able to purchase their tickets you
know so time in two weeks before that
you know for the they're doing that
because um you know there's a theater
there's a theatrical window and there's
the TV window the cable window you know
that work that's what they do is they do
it with the theatrical window and so
they know the film is about to come out
and there's a there's a window of time
that they allow these stories to come
out for people to make their plans for
the weekend at first you know with the
traditional films its box office you
know so we're dealing with a lot of the
box office things so what is it like on
those type of films they'll be you know
the week of the film it's after the
premiere so you guys film courage covers
premieres they'll tell you to wait after
the red carpet interview don't release
this until and you know in my space I
deal with a lot of stuff that's not even
just hitting releasing I'm dealing with
development acquisitions people
acquiring projects but I still have to
deal with
timing stories because we deal with you
know exclusives and given certain up and
outlets other stories so you got to be
just there's always there's always time
anyhow what's also important is you guys
have a lot of backers behind this film
and these people are your voices and I
feel that they need to support you um I
feel like you should create a press
release that's a part of the going
backwards plan you got to create a
official press release that talks about
the film who what when where why that is
premiering this is you know this is our
world premiere this is the theatrical
run this is you know why it's happening
this is who is in it and all those
details that press release can be your
template you can use that for multiple
things give it to all your 250 people
that you know contributor the film they
need to send it to all their networks in
addition to the link to purchase the
tickets you can use that tool also for
the reviewers when you're sending it to
them and the influencers when you're
saying this is your framework you know
and then if you have time you have
prepared press kit but it sounds like
we're pressed for time but you know on
the next project or keep in mind the
press gets very good because it's just
like media comes is you can email them
as a PDF and it's just a point of
reference it's got every detail the
director statement the photos hi
high-res images anything that they can
use for their coverage right but it
sounds to me like definitely a press
release definitely type into the 250
people that are backing you and if it's
any other film any other filmmaker you
know you have a you have a crew that
worked for you these people are they
want to see the film be successful as
well so I would you utilize that rally
the troops you know you're like the
Shepherd just rally them you know and
leave the charge and then and then you
know we talked about in for offline is a
the wire distribution sometimes that
it's good for just exposure you know
putting it there's some free news and
wire services out there that's just good
to put your news on the on the wire and
there's that your film remember yes it's
important that you have this theatrical
run this is the most important thing
is a huge accomplishment right no matter
how it goes you have it you got that
that's huge it was in theaters right
don't remember you're going to do
another project after this so you got to
have a point of reference so when
someone's googling your name that's your
information has to be you know it's your
credit that's your baby so it's
important it's almost like you want to
have sort of that time wall yes where
things exist at different points in time
absolutely so is that why then submitted
to a PR service would be good because
you don't know maybe you won't get
people to come out so that point in
front absolutely absolutely remember if
a news outlet does the story it's great
it's wonderful you can't control them
completely this is the reporters
interpretation of the story no matter
what happens they're gonna put their
spin on it if it's a review they're
gonna put their spin on it you want to
have your voice no matter what somewhere
so you put that on you the film's
website you put on the wire it's always
there it stays on there forever and that
brings me back to another point is the
reviews is you know you got to kind of
determine you know you got to make a
decision you know different campaigns
are like art we're gonna do a review
campaign maybe we don't want to do that
you know if you see some of these films
that are coming out of the horror
slasher film sometimes you know I think
the film's available for reviews they
just put them out and then you know
that's it so you got to make the
determination if you want to do reviews
and who you want to target um but again
with time it's it's pressed so I would
pro you know that would probably be the
first thing is sending strangers out
ASAP to the targets that you want you
know
you